Senator McCain held the record as face
the nation's most frequent guests
he appeared 112 times Wow and most of
those interviews were with CBS News
contributor Bob Schieffer who joins us
at the table also here is CBS News
senior national security analyst Fran
Townsend president george w bush's
homeland security advisor she worked
with Senator McCain on immigration
reform and describes him as a mentor and
a friend friend let's start with you
because I've heard you say that Senator
McCain was always one of the first
people you called for advice so I'm
wondering what you learned from him and
when was the last time you called him
for advice so Gayle interestingly look I
think like many what I learned from him
was country comes first interestingly it
was May of 2017
I was asked and bited down to Washington
to be interviewed for the FBI directors
job and look there had been a good deal
of scratchiness between the senator and
the president and I am an incredibly
loyal friend and so I wouldn't go down
without talking to him I wasn't sure I
wouldn't be down at all and he was at
his ranch I talked to Cindy she got him
on the phone and I told him that they
wanted me to come down and I said what
should I do and without hesitation the
senator said to me you're gonna go and I
said well but I don't want you to think
that would be disloyal to you you he
said that don't be ridiculous it's not
about me and by the way he reminded me
it's not about you it's about the
country you talk to Cindy McCain on
Friday how's the family doing well I
mean Anthony how would you expect right
I mean this was clearly coming I had
visited down at the ranch several times
cindy had been extraordinary she has
been by his side you know every day she
has been his karoke caregiver his
advocate she's been the rock of the
family but it doesn't matter that you
expect it this is of course gonna be a
difficult time for everyone in the
family Bob
Senator McCain lives so much of his life
in public even being shot down of course
over Vietnam the half a century but so
much about the last six months of his
life we know so little about you were at
his ranch in in May
what was that visit like well I'll tell
you it's it's something I will never
ever forget
he was out on the back porch that house
out there there's a creek that runs by
and these beautiful trees and there was
a little breeze and and he was in a big
hospital they had and I went the day
after the Annapolis graduation and
you'll remember that President Trump had
been the speaker there and there'd been
a lot of problem a lot of talk that
maybe some of the cadets might turn
their backs on the president or might
have some sort of a demonstration well
they didn't and as we were talking about
it
Senator McCain said to me he said I was
so proud of them I was so proud because
this was about the presidency the office
of the President and he said they
conducted themselves as they should have
yeah the more stories you hear about
John McCain though I keep thinking about
courage I keep thinking about grace that
that clip I remember at the time when
the woman said something about Barack
Obama being Arab and how he took the mic
away and said no ma'am
no ma'am that he immediately just shut
that down for him yeah I mean and so
this you know he wrote this book about
why courage matters and he really
believed it didn't mean that he never
made a mistake or anything that he
regretted but he really believed that
you had to live your life with courage
and and that meant an idealism that was
coupled with action willingness to act
that clip you mentioned is one that I
prize right because I think it's vintage
McCain it was that was not about getting
votes that was about doing the right
thing in the in that moment when you
were presented with the opportunity not
to lose them Bob he appeared on Face the
Nation 112 times and I think about what
Mark Salter his longtime aide said
McCain was a romantic about his causes
and a cynic about the world and the
reason he was on so much it was not just
because he was a favorite guy or
something like that we all liked him
very much but he was involved in almost
everything every major issue of the last
30 years he's either running for
president he's either the chairman of
the Senate Armed Services Committee he's
talking about the war in Iraq in all of
these things he was in the middle of
everything is he
placeable in the Senate right now I mean
is there is there I mean at this moment
in time his voice you know what was it
that President Eisenhower said when they
asked him can you name what Richard
Nixon has done it was his vice
presidency the thing about John McCain
and why he was such an effective
communicator he understood what we do
and he expected us to understand what he
did because they said he could get mad
at the press but already that he could
he could get upset with you and pout a
little bit but then he would carry on
sometimes do here is what sent john
mccain apart but you could always find
it you know most politicians when the
news about them is good they're easy to
find you could always find john mccain
and he was never afraid to take a human
and normal human and normal he was he
and gerald ford were the two most normal
politician that i have recovered they
were they were like real people yeah Bob
I just think too I mean much of what we
know of john mccain is appearing on your
program and on the campaign trail but
his book and i wrote about this
yesterday online just about faith and my
fathers would he learn from his fellow
POWs at the Hanoi Hilton and what they
went through and he said I fell in my it
fell in love with my country while he
was in prison for five but do you know
that was his life that was his father
that was his grandfather there's a
famous story about when John went to the
Episcopal School it was a boarding
school in Washington and it was terrible
student it was always getting into
trouble and the principal called his
father and and said this and his father
said have you caught him lying or
stealing yeah
and the principal said no and he said
we'll call me if you do all right
lucky for friends a lot thank you both
very much